now the army general who led a military
takeover in sudan last month says he
will not be part of the future
government after the transitional period
speaking exclusively to al jazeera abdul
fatt al-burhan says he is committed to a
smooth democratic transition once
elections are held in 2023
last month the military took power
dissolved the civilian arm of the
government and declared a state of
emergency
it is our pledge a pledge we made to
ourselves the sudanese people and the
international community that we are
committed to completing the democratic
transition holding elections on time and
committed to not stopping any political
activity as long as it is peaceful and
within the bounce of the constitutional
declaration and the parts that have not
been suspended we also ask the
international community to look at the
issue critically and through the reality
and wait to see what we do we are
committed to handing over power to
civilian government a government of
national competency and we pledge to
preserve the transition from any
interference that can hinder it
also denied that the army was
responsible for the deaths of protesters
who've been demonstrating against the
takeover on sunday security forces fired
tear gas at a group of teachers who were
protesting in the capital cartoon
demonstrators had set up barricades on
the first of two days of civil
disobedience several people were
arrested during that sit-in well russell
serta spoke to general burhan he has
more now from the capitol
today when i met the
army general abdulfatah al-burhan he
said that
people are free have right to peacefully
protest in the uh cities and there were
several protests going on industries the
at the the teachers union said that at
least 80 people today have been arrested
by the security forces there hasn't been
any casualties reported however the
pressure uh through the streets is
really uh ramping up and people are
putting the barricades and belong at the
barricades to
the to block the main roads in the city
which is something that the military
definitely doesn't want to see it
because it wants to get back to the
normal as soon as possible however the
civil disability its obedience is still
there and protests are
going on so he also today have talked
about the
political uh crowd the ongoing political
crisis in the country as well saying
that the talks are underway with their
political parties and the figures
including the house of prime minister
abdullah handuk to reach to a consensus
on forming a new government and he said
that he hopes
to reach to a deal within the next 24
hours despite several obstacles and
today also the prime minister the also
prime minister abdullah hamduk has met
the representatives of the different
political parties and he said that he
will accept whatever they decide to do
so as i said the army general
al burhan has said that
he hopes to reach a deal within 24 hours
despite the obstacles